[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL LEWIS: Well, hello
everyone and welcome to this GDL
on Hobbit: A Journey
Through Middle-earth.
Now I actually have
the team with me
from North Kingdom in Sweden
who built the Chrome experiment.
So I'll hand you
over to those guys,
and they can
introduce themselves.
DANIEL ISAKSSON: Hi.
I'm Daniel Isaksson, technical
director on the project
And this is my friend, Einar.
EINAR OBERG: Yeah, developer.
PAUL LEWIS: All right, guys.
Thank you for joining us.
So, I guess, the
first thing I wanted
to ask is, for anybody who's
not actually been to the site
or seen it yet,
what kind of things
should they actually expect?
What have you guys put
into that experience?
DANIEL ISAKSSON: Well,
we wanted to create
a very visual, multimedia
exploration of the characters,
locations, and everything from
the first two "Hobbit" movies.
And we're doing some small
games using WebGL and CSS.
And some dramatizations of
different scenes and locations.
PAUL LEWIS: That sounds awesome.
So what kind of technologies
or libraries or frameworks
did you have to use to bring
this whole thing together?
EINAR OBERG: For
the experiences,
we have both the WebGL-based
ones using three.js
And we have a
couple of locations
as well using CSS only.
So it can be experienced
on other browsers
than Chrome and
Firefox, on mobile.
So we could reach more people
with the actual experiences
as well.
PAUL LEWIS: So is
a lot of the code
specific to your own engine?
I mean, you mentioned
three.js there.
Did you have to craft a lot
of the engine for yourselves?
EINAR OBERG: No,
actually we used,
pretty much, three.js
as it is, which
is pretty awesome already.
And then we, for example, in
Lake-town, we had physics,
and then we used the three.js
library and the branch
with the animal.
The animal branch in that one.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
Awesome.
OK, cool.
So obviously with
something like this,
you've got a lot
of moving parts.
Like you said, there's
CSS 3D transforms.
There's WebGL.
There's audio.
There's imagery.
Just to name a few
of these things.
What was the actual workflow for
building the whole experience?
Because, as I say,
it's a complex beast.
And it has to run well.
So how did you actually
kind of build up
to what we actually get to see?
DANIEL ISAKSSON:
Well, I think it's
made up of different
parts, as you say.
And coming from the really
more creative side of it,
we usually do a lot of
animatics in After Effects,
pre-rendering 3D work from 3D
flows into each section, how
we want it to feel and look.
Then, from that, I
think it's very much
going into early prototyping.
Because when you sit
there in the room trying
to discuss a game or a
project, without having
an actual prototype
to play around with,
it's very hard
for lots of people
to get a common understanding
of what you're talking about.
But that's--
PAUL LEWIS: So did
you find that you
were making a lot of
prototypes and iterating a lot,
or did you find that you just
made one or two prototypes
and that was good enough?
I mean, how difficult was it
to arrive at something that you
felt was creatively solid?
DANIEL ISAKSSON: I think
for some of the locations,
we've done way too
many prototypes.
But it's a very
difficult experience
to create stories around and to
get something creatively that
works both to make
something as a tech demo.
I mean, it's easy to make
something that's a good story,
but maybe it doesn't suited
for a good tech demo.
And on the other
hand, we're making--
so it has been a challenge
to create stories
that works in all dimensions.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I mean, for
anybody who's not seen it,
I mean it is a phenomenal
piece of technology
that you've actually
managed to craft.
You know, the WebGL stuff,
the CSS 3D stuff, and so on.
But actually, it is,
actually, a very interesting
and fun sort of experience
from the story side,
to actually go through
these parts of the story.
And there are bits where
you scrub through the video
back and forth and read
about the characters
and the locations, and so on.
I just want to sidestep into
a bit of a discussion of WebGL
technology that I have
a lot of love for.
But debugging
WebGL, particularly,
is notoriously horrible and
difficult because sometimes
all you get is
this black screen.
And no errors, no warnings.
Just the miserable black
screen of nothingness.
So I'm curious-- kind of,
what was your, sort of,
your tool chain?
What did debugging
look like for you,
in terms of finding,
fixing, and squashing bugs?
EINAR OBERG: Yeah.
As opposite to you, that
makes your own WebGL engines,
sometimes, since we're using
the three.js, much of that
is taken care of.
And with a bit of experience,
it's quite straightforward
work, I think, to set up the
initial scenes, at least,
and avoiding that black
screen that I often
get in the very
early stages when
starting to implement
the 3D stuff.
But, once you have pointed your
camera in the right direction,
set up all the lights
and all that basic stuff,
it's pretty straightforward.
But then when moving
into debugging,
I most often used
the WebGL Inspector,
the Chrome extension.
If I want to see,
for example, what's
getting inside the
textures and, especially,
if there's dynamic textures
and post effects and stuff
like that you need to look at.
But, otherwise, the console
log is-- the console output
is pretty straightforward to
see if there's any shader issues
and stuff like that that.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, you
mentioned WebGL Inspector.
If anybody's not actually used
that, it's a Chrome extension
by one of the Chrome engineers--
sorry not Chrome engineers,
a Maps engineer
called Ben Vanik.
And it basically wraps
around all the WebGL context
and gives you a lot
of insight into what's
actually going on there.
So definitely worth checking
out if you're actually
trying to do any
work with WebGL.
So I can open A Journey Through
Middle-earth on desktop,
but I can also do it on phones
and tablets, which is, frankly,
awesome.
And this is one
of the first times
I think I've seen an
experience of this quality
available across platforms.
So suppose the obvious
question, for me, initially,
is, how did you find
the process of building
a genuinely
multi-device experience?
DANIEL ISAKSSON: Yeah.
EINAR OBERG: It was a journey.
DANIEL ISAKSSON: It
has been a journey.
It has been a learning process
for us as well as the company
because we haven't been
too much into that before.
But, I mean, from
the beginning, it
was a big hurdle to decide
what to do with platforms that
didn't support
WebGL, for example.
How to handle that.
How to communicate with
all different kinds
of mobile devices that couldn't
support the experience.
But from that point,
I think we found
it pretty similar to
normal web development,
in terms of actually
building the website.
Of course, there are
limitations to it
that you have to abide to.
PAUL LEWIS: Well,
that was actually
going to be my next question.
So, kind of, there are
obvious constraints.
You know, on the
one hand, you've
got these desktops
with these meaty GPUs.
On the other hand, you've got
little handheld smartphones,
which are going to
punish you if you
do the slightest thing wrong.
How did you actually deal
with those constraints?
You sort of mentioned
that you had
to decide what would go
in, what would go out.
Can you just talk a bit
more about that process
and how you decided what
to include where and so on?
EINAR OBERG: Yeah, I guess the
biggest hurdle was the memory
consumption.
because you can pretty
much hit the roof
and crash the device if you're
not really careful with that.
So loading different
assets, for one thing.
And not only for memory,
for performance as well.
Because if you're using a
smaller asset and scale it up,
it's less video
memory, as well, when
you push big [? stuff ?] around.
So that helps the GPU as well.
PAUL LEWIS: You've sort
of taken a little bit
of a wander into my
next question actually.
Something I wanted
to talk to you
about is the fact that this
thing's running fantastically
well.
Astonishing, actually,
just how well
this thing runs
on mobile devices,
in particular, where
you'd be a bit concerned--
or I would definitely be a
bit concerned when you're
talking WebGL and 3D transforms.
Just generally that you want
to keep this stuff running fast
because otherwise there's
no point in including it.
It's just going to
frustrate the user.
So what were your
performance considerations
and how did you
actually make sure
that you were going to
stay at 60 frames a second
or as close as you
possibly could to that?
EINAR OBERG: We thought
that-- we didn't really
aim at reaching the 60
frames per second on mobile.
We felt that it's
much more important
that we keep a stable
frame rate at a lower frame
rate than pushing it up to 60.
So if it could be
like around 30,
that's enough if you
don't have this jank where
the frame skipping is going on.
So I guess the eye is
much more forgiving
if it's not glitches in there.
DANIEL ISAKSSON: I mean,
that took a lot of testing.
EINAR OBERG: Yeah, of course.
A lot of iterations to
make running smooth.
DANIEL ISAKSSON:
Lots of devices,
running from quite
low-end devices
to the newest, most
performance devices.
EINAR OBERG: But
then, of course, we
disabled stuff on
low-end devices.
Post effects.
We reduced the size of the
canvas that is drawn, too.
And yeah, all the
tricks that needed.
PAUL LEWIS: So did you--
DANIEL ISAKSSON: Sorry.
PAUL LEWIS: I was going
to ask, did you, then,
have to keep a bunch
of these devices
around in your studio to just
kind of step through and go,
OK, now how is this
running on this device?
And now, how is this
I mean that seems like a
big process to go through.
Were you able to automate?
Or was this just something
that you actually
had to step through
and do yourselves
every time you made a release?
DANIEL ISAKSSON:
Well, for once, we
had a dedicated
tester that actually
was responsible for constantly
testing out new versions
that we released.
But in development maybe
you can answer that?
EINAR OBERG: Yeah, of course,
we used multiple devices
during development.
And there is so big
difference between them.
And, for example, the LG
Metro with super tiny screen
up to the Nexus 10.
And also with different GPUs
and screen sizes and, I mean,
the pixel density and stuff.
So, of course, we
had many iterations
of testing on different devices.
DANIEL ISAKSSON: I guess
one of the biggest hurdles
is the ratio between
amount of pixels,
like density, and screen
size and the CPU and GPU.
Because some devices had way too
many pixels for their own good.
PAUL LEWIS: They look
amazing, but they're not
as forgiving, I guess, when
it comes to performance.
Yeah, OK.
So what are you, looking
back over this project now,
what would you say you're most
proud of from the whole thing?
I guess both from a
creative point of view,
but also a technical
point of view.
You can, you know, go crazy.
Whatever you like.
DANIEL ISAKSSON: Should I talk?
EINAR OBERG: Yeah.
DANIEL ISAKSSON: I think
my thing I'm most proud of
is that we managed to make the
experience feel very tight.
Like an app that isn't glitchy.
That really went that
extra mile to try to--
even though we have to unload
each section between sections
and load the next one, so on,
to keep memory consumption low.
I think we managed that by
putting hard work with doing
translation, transitions to and
from the different sections.
Trying to keep this
audio as fluent
throughout the
experience as possible.
So I'm very--
EINAR OBERG: Yeah, so
you don't feel it's a gap
and then you have to
load and load and load.
So we had-- it's, of course,
many loaders in this site
as well because
it's pretty large.
But since we load smaller
chunks and then we
show a splash screen
and load the rest,
it feels like you can let
the user be immersed instead
of just sit around
waiting for a long time.
PAUL LEWIS: It
does, to me-- I know
North Kingdom has a very rich
history in Flash-- it actually
feels a lot more like
the latter stages
that we had with a
lot of the Flash work,
where studios were getting very
experienced with when to unload
and load to try and
keep the user engaged.
And it feels like
a lot of that stuff
is still very applicable today.
Even though we're delivering
in HTML, JavaScript, CSS,
WebGL, all those
technologies, it still
feels like a lot
of those techniques
are still valid and
still useful and helpful.
What do you guys think?
DANIEL ISAKSSON: Yeah,
I mean, often the brief
is still the same.
The brief from the
client and the goal
you're trying to achieve.
And so that's not changing.
And that's why we
always have thought
that, to get really
immersed into an experience,
it has to really have
that love in every pixel.
PAUL LEWIS: So before you
started on the whole project,
did you have any assumptions
about how this was going
to play out or what
it was going to be
like that you, then, during
the project, you just thought,
wow, we were so wrong with that.
You know.
Did you have any assumptions
that were basically
blown to pieces
throughout the build
and the creative
work that you did?
EINAR OBERG: I guess one thing
is we didn't really thought
that the performance would be
that good on devices, actually.
So, early in the
project, we had a lot
of discussions what
we actually could do.
And we need to have super simple
version for mobile devices.
But then, gradually, we could
add more and more and more.
I'm personally
pretty amazed what
you can do devices these days.
And, right now, it
takes a really long time
to make a site like this.
But I think that in
a very short future,
we will take this for granted,
that we use mobile in this way
when making sites like this.
DANIEL ISAKSSON: I think
one thing, for example,
is the 3D models we used
in WebGL experiments.
From the beginning,
we really set the aim
on using much lower poly
counts, less complex models.
But that is something that we
kept raising for some parts.
It has worked.
PAUL LEWIS: That is awesome.
I asked the question having
no idea what you'd actually
answer with and I'm so happy
that your answer is, things
perform better than
we thought they would.
But, on the other
side, if you could
change one thing
about the web platform
that would have perhaps
made this whole thing
a bunch easier,
what would it be?
What would you change
about building for the web?
DANIEL ISAKSSON: I think
we really discussed hard
when heard you were going
to put this question.
And we don't really
have a good answer.
One thing, that usually is the
big blocker and that always
comes up in discussions is
integrated video on mobile.
To be able to create
interactive video experiences.
Because that's something
we're getting most every brief
from our clients.
But there's a reason
why that's the case.
And I'm not sure it would be
a better world going that way.
PAUL LEWIS: Ok.
Awesome.
EINAR OBERG: I would say
also that to have a better
workflow with animations
and vector-based graphics,
there's so many techniques
that you can use,
and it's scattered
all over the place.
Maybe not changing the platform,
but the workflow for us
developers to get all those
techniques under the same roof.
Use them easier.
PAUL LEWIS: Awesome.
OK.
So something like this is--
an experience like A Journey
Through Middle-earth
is naturally very
cutting edge in what
it's trying to do
and the techniques
that you used.
Were there any resources
that you relied on
or that you looked at
to help you build it
as you were going through?
Or was it just
something that you just
had to iterate
through on your own
and just kind of
hope for the best?
EINAR OBERG: I think that how
the development community looks
like now is we
haven't had it easier
than this to find
answers and stuff.
Because you use dependencies
and components and GitHub
and Twitter.
It's so easy to get access
to not only the ones
that wrote the code
from the beginning,
but all the communities behind.
Like IRC channel on three.js.
All these people
there are helpful,
can just quickly answer
if you have anything.
And so I think
it's a great place.
PAUL LEWIS: It sounds like
people power is basically
the answer.
You know, IRC, Twitter, GitHub.
Go to the people.
There are loads of really
experienced and helpful
developers that will
actually help you,
kind of, get to
your end goal, yeah?
EINAR OBERG: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Well,
there are two articles
by you guys on HTML5 Rocks,
which I really recommend,
that steps through, in
a bit more detail, some
of the technical
challenges that you faced.
And if you've not seen A Journey
Through Middle-earth yet,
definitely go and
check that out.
It's well worth the time to just
explore every nook and cranny.
I had one heck of a time trying
to get all the correct answers
to Smaug and not get
burned to a crisp.
But that's definitely
worth your time, as well.
It's plenty fun listening
to Benedict Cumberbatch.
There is his dragon thing.
But all the same,
in any case, guys,
thank you so much for taking
some time out and catch you
next time.
EINAR OBERG: Thanks
for having us.
DANIEL ISAKSSON: Thank you.